ford qui fabrique des voitures du genre
classique passe à la mini traction avant
c'est un événement dans l'histoire de
l'automobile
trois portes trois mètres cinquante six
cinq et six chevaux la fiesta est une
très jolie voiture la plus petite jamais
construite chez ford
[Musique]
moteur transversal en trois versions 9
157 cm cube 40 et 45 chevaux et 1117
centimètres cubes 53 chevaux boîte 4
rapports et bien sûr traction avant
suspension tube rigide arrière et jambes
élastique à l'avant habitabilité quatre
vraies places
[Musique]
porte arrière sans seuil et un coffre de
200 litres avec un compartiment secret
[Musique]
cette malle passe à plus d'un mètre cube
un rabattant la banquette arrière
[Musique]
comme d'habitude un équipement variable
en fonction des modèles mais en tout cas
une excellente qualité de finition et
une bonne disposition générale des
commandes
[Musique]
à noter une grande facilité d'entretien
et de réparation
[Musique]
essuie glace arrière jantes alliage
léger et options toit ouvrant
translucide pour la guia modèle le plus
luxueux et le comportement routier bon
dans l'ensemble malgré quelques
réactions parasites de la suspension
direction merveilleuse de douceur
excellente boîte de vitesses confort
satisfaisant performances correctes
consommation raisonnable de 7 à 9 litres
aux cent mes freinages à revoir le
cerveau frein est indispensable
ambitieuse la fiesta sera produite à
près de 500000 exemplaires dès l'an
prochain et la france sera son premier
marché
le pdg de ford france vignal nous l'a
d'ailleurs confirmé avec 20000 vente
prévue d'ici la fin de l'année et 50 à
60 mille ans 77
la fiesta existants six modèles de la
cinq chevaux spéciale à 17 milles 900
francs à la cie cheveau gars à 24000 260
francs
[Musique]